[Musique]
bienvenue dans le sky échos et comme à
chaque édition nous vous racontons les
aventures économique du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines dans ce numéro
40 découverte de mon baluchon une start
up créée par sophie et coralie un site
internet de vente et de livraison
produits alimentaires et non
alimentaires en vrac rencontre avec
fabien joseph ce jeune saint quentinois
de 24 ans est actuellement en alternance
chez rdi manager une start up
spécialisée dans la gestion de
l'innovation puis d'un crédit agricole
est actuellement dans une campagne de
recrutement le groupe bancaire on
recrute notamment un responsable
d'application monétique sur le site de
sky parc et on commence avec la nouvelle
campagne de recrutement du ski cube
l'incubateur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance un
nouvel appel à candidatures les porteurs
de projets ou de services d'innovation
technologique et les dirigeants de start
up candidate et jusqu'au 24 juin les
lauréats pourront bénéficier du
programme d'incubation de 6 à 24 mois
d'un accompagnement personnalisé et
avoir du soutien d'experts thématiques
et depuis son ouverture il ya cinq ans
l'incubateur à épauler une soixantaine
d'entreprises
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez nouvel échange je
m'appelle sophie keller je suive
cofondatrice de l'entreprise avec mon
associé coralie mon baluchon c'est quoi
c'est ainsi des commerces de proximité
de vendre de produits vrac alimentaire
et non alimentaire français bio locaux
et zéro déchet
[Musique]
mon baluchon a été créée donc en mars
2022 on a débuté notre activité le 29
avril dernier voilà le site a ouvert à
ce moment là les gens commentent sur
notre site en ligne voilà les produits
et leurs contenants puisqu'on a
plusieurs types de contenants des bocaux
des recherches kraft biodégradable mais
aussi des bouteilles consignées voilà et
ensuite ils choisissent leurs modes de
livraison donc livraison à domicile sur
le lieu de travail ou en retrait click
and collect et bien du coup ce matin on
va livrer donc sur un lieu de travail à
domicile et on va aussi recevoir
potentiellement une cliente en retrait
en click and collect
[Musique]
quand clients commandent sur internet la
commande tombe sur notre back office on
la voit apparaître on regarde le jour de
la livraison ou du clic qu'elles
collectent et on prépare sa commande au
plus tôt la vrille
[Musique]
j'ai imprimé les étiquettes de la
commande la commande qui est tombée sur
sur internet donc on a décidé de le
choix de faire des étiquettes et
d'indiquer un conseil d'utilisation très
pratique pour le consommateur
par exemple le temps de cuisson là nous
avons 500 g de pois chiches donc nous
allons aller vers les pois chiches
[Musique]
tous nos aliments sont dans des boîtes
hermétiques
pour un côté de conservation des
aliments cette cliente a fait le choix
du papier kraft pour le pois chiche donc
elle doit certainement déjà avoir ses
propres mots qu elle n'aura qu'à
recharger
donc pour les pois chiches le producteur
est situé à benne et ils viennent de lui
de l'huilerie de la plaine de versailles
nous travaillons avec des producteurs
essentiellement locaux
donc des yvelines autant que possible et
sinon du ca reste du français on a fait
un sourcil niasse et sérieux des
producteurs nous notre engagement c'est
vraiment la qualité des produits
donc on a on s'est mis en contact avec
plusieurs fournisseurs et on a
sélectionné les français les locaux les
bios ou agriculture raisonnée les pois
chiches sont prêts nous allons
maintenant passer aux haricots blancs et
elle veut 500 grammes
[Musique]
pour notre lancement aujourd'hui nous
avons en tout au total 140 références
différentes sur notre site internet et
nous sommes sans cesse en train de
sources et de nouveaux produits pour
répondre à la demande de nos clients
chez nous vous pouvez retrouver aussi
bien dans toute la partie alimentaire
épicerie sèche sucrés et salés la partie
non alimentaire donc ça peut être les
produits d'hygiène et beauté les
produits ménagers des accessoires et un
rayon animal également donc là nous
avons terminé la commande pour le
chocolat en poudre la dame a choisi un
bocal
donc on retrouve bien la provenance est
ainsi que le conseil d'utilisation
la personne qui choisit un bocal pour sa
première commande le bocal et à elle
ensuite elle l'a payé et à la prochaine
commande elle pourra utiliser uniquement
du craft et recharger ses bocaux
[Musique]
le périmètre c'est les communautés
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
saint quentin en yvelines et la haute
vallée de chevreuse on dessert aussi
quelques communes périphériques style
gif-sur-yvette ou encore saclay où
l'ancien il sera amené à s'étendre oui
mais pas tout de suite pour l'instant
veut déjà pouvoir vraiment fidéliser la
clientèle sur le périmètre en question
l'activité a démarré doucement la
première semaine beaucoup de livraisons
de retraités ken collecte de notre
réseau personnel un famille amis voilà
et dès la deuxième semaine on a commencé
à avoir des commandes de clients qu'on
ne connaît pas parce qu'on a pas mal
communiquer notamment sur sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
voici votre commande dernière commande
oui votre première commande alors au
lieu de travail c'est pas fort pratique
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette livraison
express dans les temps
vous avez reçu un sms jusqu'à vendre
votre fiston d'avancé ok on n'a pas de
tout petits oui là on va au delà
versailles
[Musique]
là bas qui a commandé il ya la semaine
dernière et qui du coup nous a passé une
grosse commande là il ya une dizaine de
produits que aussi bien que ce soit
alimentaire il ya beaucoup appris
beaucoup d'épicerie
d'épicerie sèche chalets et quelques uns
produits ménagers je crois une lessive
est également des accessoires pour pour
la cuisine et la salle de bains au tout
départ se fier moi comment c'est connu
c'est parce qu'on a et on a emménagé
dans un immeuble neuf à voisins le
bretonneux donc on a emménagé le même
jour en fait tous les habitants ont
emménagé le même jour et j'ai eu le
malheur de me garer sur sa place de
parking donc j'ai retrouvé un petit mot
sur ma voiture et donc je suis allé
m'excuser auprès d'elle en sonnant à sa
porte c'était ma voisine de palier en
fait et voilà comment on s'est connus
donc après on était plus que voisine on
était amis on est on s'est rencontré en
2014 et donc ans
2021 on a commencé à réfléchir à a monté
notre notre société et à travailler
ensemble on sait que
la planète pas mal entre
part en tant que parent on a envie que
bonnes conditions
ces valeurs
faire en sorte que
voilà que tout à chacun puisse y
contribuer en créant notre antre
permettant à tout à chacun sont
différents déchets facilement pouvoir on
a envie tout un chacun puisse eux
et à sa manière être entrepreneur
aujourd'hui
ça permet de construire quelque chose de
se sentir utile d'être concret dans nos
actions quotidien
et
bonjour madame
alors je vous lis moi votre deuxième
commande c'est ça je crois c'est que la
première vous a plu exactement mais non
c'était top donc j'ai préféré le gym
j'ai commandé en plus gros
donc l'engin de livraison nous reste un
click and collect à finir de préparer
pour un retrait à midi donc suivez moi
on fait du retrait en click and collect
deux fois par semaine le lundi et jeudi
pour l'instant ce sont ces jours là ça
sera certainement amené à évoluer donc
entre midi et deux et le soir à partir
de 16 heures jusqu'à 19 heures
[Musique]
plaçons des biscuits en fait de
feucherolles
qui sont confectionnés et fabriquer
là-bas c'est par les deux gourmands
voilà donc c'est encore une fois un
produit local un producteur local
[Musique]
est pour l'a donc ma cour monde
est très fine il a préparé
ces deux là ce sont des commandes en
retrait click and collect pour
aujourd'hui voilà
[Musique]
je m'appelle ce terme de la terrasse et
je suis responsable rh chez crédit
agricole payment services
crédit agricole perd mains de services
it est une filiale du groupe crédit
agricole leader des solutions de
paiement en france avec près de 30% de
parts de marché credit agricole payment
service is conçoit et développe des
solutions de paiement innovantes dans un
marché dynamique et en perpétuelle
transformation ont recruté en recherche
régulièrement des profils d'ingénieurs
qui sont passionnés par l'innovation et
le monde des paiements nous recherchons
un poste à pourvoir sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines celui de responsable
d'application monétiques à destination
des commerçants ce métier consiste à
mettre à disposition des solutions de
paiement pour les commerçants
concrètement en quoi ça consiste
eh bien le responsable d'application
doit délivrer des projets donc
comprendre le besoin du client lui
proposait d'une solution adaptée et puis
après réaliser un cahier des charges
ensuite il doit participer à la
construction de cette solution
informatique cette application est enfin
il doit assurer une veille technologique
pour justement concevoir des solutions
de paiement de demain nous recherchons
des profils d'ingénieurs passionné par
les nouvelles technologies des
compétences informatiques bien sûr ici
du monde de lahti spécifiquement une
maîtrise des tartines architecture & cie
et puis avec des personnes ayant un bon
sens relationnel une orientation client
voilà ça ce sont des atouts que nous
recherchons
je m'appelle fabien joseph je suis
business developer en alternance dans la
start-up francilienne erdei manager et
on développe un logiciel de gestion de
projets à destination des entreprises
innovantes du secteur
[Musique]
lors du manager s'est situé à la trappe
dans une pépinière d'entreprises qui
s'appelle trisa lead donc profitent de
cet emplacement car on est dans le
plateau de paris saclay qui est une
terre d'innovation dans les yvelines
[Musique]
je suis arrivé en février 2021 je suis
venu ici alors qu'avant j'étais en
alternance chez psa j'ai démissionné de
mon poste chez psa parce que j y avait
une opportunité en start up et j'avais
envie d'en
dans une expérience qui bouge qui est
très motivante où l'idée prises en
compte j'ai choisi une start-up parce
que ça correspond parfaitement mon
profil je suis quelqu'un de dynamique
proactif
j'avais vraiment besoin d'avoir du
travail d'avoir plusieurs tâches à
résoudre dans un temps imparti
[Musique]
son activité au quotidien consiste à
faire connaître rdi manager au plus
grand nombre le doit établir un plan
d'action sur le lancement commercial du
produit
donc c'est à dire création de bases de
données appels de clients contacts
clients bien mail rencontre avec les
clients présentation démonstration du
produit et s ajoute à ça toutes les
tâches de communication où je gère toute
la page linkedin de rdi manager m'occupe
aussi de la présence dehors des managers
au salon
lié à l'innovation
je suis sur un rythme de 3 jours en
entreprise et deux jours en école j'ai
effectué ma formation à sensia business
school qui est une école de commerce à
saint quentin en yvelines je suis un
master en management et stratégie
d'entreprise le rythme je me le suis
approprié au fil du temps
effectivement parfois c'est difficile de
faire la part des choses quand on a
beaucoup de devoirs à faire avec l'école
des rendus de groupe des rendus de
synthèse et en même temps au travail
quand il ya des échéances donc pour
gérer tout ça il faut vraiment avoir un
emploi du temps vraiment bien structuré
[Musique]